and we're back with the fox news alert
as america retreats from afghanistan it
didn't take long for russia and china to
fill the power vacuum as the rest of the
world was evacuating their embassies in
kabul not russia and china they were
keeping their doors open signifying
their willingness to work with the
taliban
and with america out of the picture
china is now the major economic force in
the region reuters said the following
china can now deliver aid investment and
technical support chinese state minors
can help afghanistan exploit its vast
mineral reserves valued at over three
trillion dollars according to officials
and that's from 2017
but as the communist nation clamps down
on freedoms in hong kong and
preferably in taiwan if they had their
own way they're beginning their warnings
they told the taiwanese people this they
said america will abandon them too look
at this this is from state media who
tweeted from what happened in
afghanistan those in taiwan should
perceive that once a war breaks out in
the straits the island's defenses will
collapse in hours and u.s military won't
come to help
so has our withdrawal embolden china is
this one of the costs of the collapse of
the last 72 hours david tafari is a
former obama state department official
and he joins me now david thank you for
being with me
how do you think people are sleeping
tonight in taiwan i can't imagine
soundly
well that tweet is from global times
global times is just a newspaper that's
a mouthpiece for the chinese communist
party so that's propaganda that's
chinese
fear-mongering in taiwan trying to worry
taiwan the situation between america and
taiwan is very different from
afghanistan we don't have troops in
taiwan haven't for a long time but we've
had over a 70 year alliance it's a
complicated alliance but we've stood by
taiwan we don't have
a security promise
the two points that you make so far i
would think would make the taiwanese
people even more nervous you're telling
me that a warning came from official
state media propaganda that means they
might mean what they say that's coming
from the chinese government what more
you point out that the united states
doesn't have troops in taiwan well the
afghan people just watched as thousands
of troops abandoned that country in a
matter of hours so if you're living in a
country where american troops had a
presence and now you are living under
the rule of the taliban how do you think
people living in a country where there
is no american troop presence must feel
when they have an official warning on
their hands
well it's not news to the people of
taiwan that china opposes them and
opposes their democracy everyone in
taiwan is aware of that and aware of
that threat but it might be news that
the united states of america might not
be there to back them up
yeah well i mean let's talk about that
you know the videos are coming out of
kabul are concerning and should be
concerning to all
but the deal for us to leave afghanistan
was signed by president trump in
february 2020 and people seem to forget
that on your show
it was president trump that did this
deal in fact under his deal he would
have had all american forces out of
afghanistan by may it was biden that
extended it until september so this was
a foregone conclusion that biden
followed after trump did it remember
also president trump gave 5 000 taliban
prisoners and released them in order to
get the deal a pretty bad deal in the
first place and many of those 5 000
taliban fighters have rejoined the
taliban david i don't think anybody on
this program is foreign supported
leaving afghanistan it's possible you
were getting your mic and your ifb
plugged in during the first segment of
the show so you might not have heard us
talk about that very fact but we make a
very important point which is a factual
and truth-seeking point to distinguish
about whether or not we leave
afghanistan with how we leave
afghanistan and the point we're getting
at today is who steps into our vacuum
when we step out and leave chaos the way
that joe biden and our military leaders
have left in the last 72 hours we see
immediately that our adversaries in
china and russia step up and i would
have to think we don't have to focus
specifically on taiwan if you're a
united states ally in the middle east if
you're a united states ally anywhere in
this world but most specifically if
you're a united states ally in taiwan
you would look at the last 72 hours and
think i'm not sure we can trust the
united states of america
but then you seem to be arguing that we
should have kept the troops in
afghanistan for a long time for the
foreseeable future and i think there is
an argument that we should have but once
president trump signed the deal to pull
the troops out from afghanistan this was
always going to happen and whether it
was under biden or under troop there was
joe biden one month ago and actually
said one month ago this wouldn't happen
though but you said this was always
going to happen that's the same thing
joe biden said today but i could roll
the tape from less than a month ago of
joe biden saying this would never happen
i think everyone knew it was going to
eventually happen it happened more
quickly because the taliban gained
strength very quickly it snowballed in
many towns and cities they switched over
when they saw that the taliban was
gaining in power because they care most
about their own safety and so that's why
it happened so quickly but it was always
going to happen and actually so far
although it looks really bad it's not as
bad as it could have been there aren't
reprisal killings yet in kabul and there
may be and i'll be the one of the first
people complaining about it if it
happens but there aren't so far yet
reprisal killings and we still don't
exactly know what the taliban is going
to do the taliban is committed to having
an inclusive government i personally am
very skeptical of that but there are
people in by administration certainly in
the trump administration who still
believe that taliban is not the taliban
of the 1990s and it might have an
inclusive government and let's see
the taliban might just have an inclusive
government right i'm sure that's
something we can all hold our breath to
see maybe they will follow for example
some of the guidance in the united
states that we can rename breast feeding
chest feeding i'm sure that's the kind
of expectation we should hold for
we look at the taliban i said i'm
skeptical i appreciate that skepticism
i'll tell you i appreciate that
skepticism i think it's more than
skepticism i think it's realism and i
will tell you that i hope in the future
the united states bar isn't simply to
cross no reprisal killings i hope we can
do better than mass chaos and i hope we
can do better than lies over a one month
period time i hope we can do better than
what we've heard from the bite
administration in the last month and i
think the people of taiwan and israel
and every other ally across this world
are hoping that maybe all they're left
with hope but hoping for the same thing
from this great country i appreciate you
being with me tonight david
thank you all right up next
it's back to school time for students
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else